das sind echte helden es war ein
großartiger einsatz wir haben gerade
auch in der gedenk vereine darauf im
kiliansdom in würzburg
genau darüber gesprochen unser
ministerpräsident hat sich für dieses
großartige engagement ausdrücklich
bedanken ebenso der würzburger
oberbürgermeister und ministerpräsident
würde wird auch überlegen inwieweit eben
die menschen die so geholfen haben wie
wir das gerade hier gesehen und gehört
haben hier besonders geehrt werden in
allernächster zeit für dieses
couragierte eintreten es gibt eine
bayerische rettungsmedaille für menschen
die um das scheint mir jedoch der fall
zu sein ihr eigenes leben aufs spiel
setzten um andere menschenleben zu
retten
das muss jetzt noch mal angeschaut
werden aber ich meine wirklich das ist
ein sehr couragiertes ein heldenhaftes
verhalten und auch die polizei sagte
damit sind zumindest noch mal in der
gesamten zeitlichen ablauf wie sie den
dargestellt haben vielleicht die
entscheidende minute nochmal dieser
täter hingehalten worden bis dann
wirklich der erste polizeibeamte vor ort
eintraf und mit seiner schusswaffe den
täter endgültig stoppen konnte sonst
wäre womöglich in dieser minute plus
minus um die es geht schon wieder
weitere menschen diesem täter zum opfer
gefallen insofern spricht wirklich alles
dafür dass diese menschen mit ihren
heldenhaften eintreten anderen menschen
das leben gerettet haben